tony is going to start off this hour in
new york city hi tony welcome to the
dave ramsey show
what's up dave what's up john how are
you guys great man how can we help
yeah so i'm a 22 year old college senior
i got one year left
um i have no debt my mom paid cash for
the school so i'm good
wow um i had a job back in march
um but i lost it because it covered and
uh so i just decided to sign up for
unemployment because
all of my friends were kind of doing it
and i ended up getting about 18
000 from unemployment i'm guessing
that's free money i don't know if it's
taxable
actually they took out taxes um and so
um i was wondering like what's like the
best way for me to go
so that i can basically like be
financially free or like wealthy like
how you call it because i just found you
like a day yesterday actually
oh my goodness well well done sir so
what is your degree in
going to be in so i'm setting up finance
okay and the the the job that you had
lined up was
for for after you completed your degree
no it was just a job just for income for
money oh actually
okay and you graduate when now i
graduate in two semesters
so this time next year yeah about
okay all right well i think you hold on
to that money to ensure that you
graduate
and uh continue the debt-free journey
that you're on which is absolutely
awesome
that's very very cool have you hugged
your mom today tony if you told her that
you loved her and she set you up to win
i probably should thought i'd just say
that tony every day you wake up you go
tell that lady
thank you for setting me up for for a
life
yeah that is going to be debt-free it's
it's yeah cause it's just wonderful very
few people get the gift that you've
gotten here so
it's just not i'm very lucky for you i
just wanted to know like what's like the
best way for me like
it's it's not the best question but it's
very general
but like what's the best way for me to
to get
wealthy like like i don't want to say
rich but like wealthy is like the best
way
yeah well either one's okay
neither one are immoral it's not immoral
to be rich it's not immoral
you're not a bad person automatically if
you're wealthy and so one thing you do
want to do is break that out of your
head
uh and and so because if you're other
centered
you can do a lot of wonderful things
with money like your mom did
okay she used money to do this
wonderful thing for you and you'll be
able to do that uh yourself many times
over so
yeah it's a big question it's probably
too big for a radio answer
i'll tell you the biggest thing a couple
things number one is
to be doing what you're doing now gather
knowledge be very intentional
with your money most people just kind of
wander along and then wonder what
happened
and if you'll just be very intentional
then that will lead you to
doing a budget that will lead you to
living on less than you make
that will lead you to generosity that
will lead you to
avoiding debt that will lead you to
investing and those are the keys
to building wealth but no one does that
accidentally no one wins the super bowl
on accident
it's an intentional act and so
just by asking the question you've
started that process
of being intentional so dave there's a
lot of media sensations
that that pop up with you know a couple
of college friends come up with an idea
and they
they have an ipo and they turn into
overnight this is and that's
is it been your experience though that
the the vast majority of people who
build and i love
that he already knows the distinction
here to build wealth
it takes a long time doesn't it yeah get
rich quick just does not work right
statistically uh so it's so rare
and the interesting thing is those that
do it very seldom keep it
and so because they didn't build the
infrastructure in their character to
carry it
and it is well i like that it fritters
away you build the muscles by increment
by struggle after struggle after
struggle because a muscle is a
built by tearing muscle is built by
destruction
by by pain and it's not built by comfort
and so that that gradual over a 10 12
15 year period of uh uh
of staying out of debt living on a
lesson you make being intentional
uh doing some things that your friends
don't do
not doing a bunch of things your friends
do do you know and that kind of a thing
you have a life but you're just very
smart and wise about it over a period of
time
that is how wealth is built i talked to
a young man this morning 35 years old
came up to me and whispered and said i'm
an everyday millionaire wow
and uh works on our team really yeah wow
walked up to me after staff meeting and
said i'm an everyday millionaire 30 i
said how old are you
35. i mean he said i started working
your plan 12 years ago
just out of college he said i've all
we've always lived
exactly what we teach here to the dime
to the penny
you know intentional and um he makes
good money but he doesn't you know
yeah he he didn't get paid a million
dollars a year i'll tell you that
millionaire money right now he doesn't
make millionaire money but he is
right because he just just that steady
the tortoise wins the race not the hair
every time yeah and that's the you know
all the data we have on millionaires
tells us that's how they do it
and that same idea works for marriages
for mental health for physical health
for weight loss
yeah you said that right when i came on
i don't even know if you remember saying
that to me but you said john i've read
that book that tortoise in the hair a
whole bunch
and the tortoise wins every single time
beverly hills said there's no
shortcut to any place worth going i love
it it's just that's the process
sorry tony good for you brother hang on
tony we're gonna give you a copy of the
book the total money makeover
which has shown eight million people how
to answer the question you're asking
this is the dave ramsey show